[Music]
drug companies say there'll be enough
doses to vaccinate most of the world
against covert
by the end of the year industrialized
nations are way ahead
but out of the one and a half billion
shots given so far
only point three percent has gone to the
globe's poorest countries
barriers are plentiful vaccines are
fiddly to make and challenging to
transport
then there are the politics and money
[Music]
experts warn it's bad for everyone if
only a fraction of us
are protected
many developing countries are still
waiting for vaccines promised by the
kovacs donation program
china gave 200 000 doses to chad this
month
the first vaccine to reach the country
where officials are trying to fight the
pandemic with limited testing and
treatment capabilities
dw's west africa correspondent fred
mavornii reports
at last chad has weapon against the
pandemic
sino-farm vaccines for at least a
hundred thousand people
not much for a population of 16 million
but it's something this is the country's
main testing facility
in the honorary proper hospital they
have been fighting the chronovirus
almost
brined last situation
the covey the 19 situation was scary at
the beginning
we tested patients who came to hospital
and some of them tested positive
some of the health workers and other
patients died of kovid 19.
official figures show less than 5000
infections
and fewer than 200 covered 19 deaths
the real numbers are almost certainly
higher
as testing and healthcare infrastructure
is so poor
that creek infrastructure and political
instability left chad
near the bottom of the list for
international vaccine help
until last week when the coved 19 task
force got supplies
from china
when we received synophan vaccines
it was really a great joy for us
health workers perigrams going to
america
and patients with pre-existing
conditions are a priority
officials know the chinese donation can
only be the first step
these fridges are ready for vaccines yet
to come
a vector mechanism under the covert
program
we will get doses that will vaccinate at
least 20 percent
of the population of chad
only a few come from vaccines many are
skeptical of
its origins if we had the means to get
other vaccines
we could but if we don't have the means
and this can protect us just because
it's a chinese vaccine
doesn't mean it's bad sinofarm vaccine
doesn't yet have european or u.s
approval
but the world health organization says
it offers
up to 79 percent protection
in charge people are used to taking what
they can get
elizabeth masouda is from doctors
without borders nice to see you again
that report made one thing very clear
the vaccine distribution
is totally unequal what's the main
problem in your opinion
i think the main problem is that the
distribution
through covax as it was originally
planned so that kovacs could be an
international distribution mechanism
then was undermined by
bilateral deals that were made by the us
by the uk
also the european union and they
basically bought up the vaccine market
so there was
little left over for kovacs to actually
distribute to poorer countries
and now with the stock of expectations
from india and the
heavily reliance of the kovacs mechanism
on the supply from the serum institute
of india
we see this is a great problem and
therefore there are not many vaccines
left over and in the
report it said by the end of the year 20
of chadians will be
able to be vaccinated through kovacs
that is probably a number that can't be
reached
at the rate that corvex is going so
kovacs
doesn't work does it
it does work in the sense that it does
supply vaccines to
the poorer countries but it does not
reach its goals that it has set itself
so it was supposed to by june this year
reached 3.3 of the point percent of the
populations but it has only reached 25
percent of this
and as i said till the end of the year
kovacs was supposed to supply 2 billion
doses of vaccines it looks like now
only half of that number will be reached
production is obviously a problem as
we've mentioned a few days ago though
the european parliament called
for a temporary waiver of patents which
would allow
poorer countries to produce their own
vaccines
how hopeful are you that that will
finally happen
we've seen now in talks and
announcements that there are more
that companies will be more open or
supposed to be more open for also more
voluntary licensing deals and for
technology transfer
we hope that this can happen fast
studies have shown that within six
months
technology transfer can happen also for
mrna-based vaccines
so we urge countries but also companies
to quickly
attack transfer so that we can have a
scale-up of production
because as we see the distribution is
unequal and when we have
more dis production worldwide we will
have less dependencies on a few
producers that we have at the moment
but elizabeth these pharma giants aren't
just going to give up their technology
for free are they
well they have received billions of
dollars in tax
taxpayer funding and public funding so i
think at this point it would be key
to share the technology that has been
also developed as
in the case with mrna also with public
funding
so it's something that we're saying in
this case
there have already been profits made by
companies like faisal and bayern tech
like moderner
they have made profits already and now
it's time in this global pandemic
to share the technology share the
patents or actually lift the patents
so that there can be a scale up of
production because as we've seen we are
not managing
to reach the goals that we wanted to
reach and yeah people in poor countries
are waiting for their vaccines
so governments need to put pressure on
these companies i mean it was
governments
that did these deals with these
companies and gave these companies our
taxpayer money
why don't they see the problem here
i think we see a little bit of a divide
between the rhetorics and the words
being used and saying
the pandemic will end only when it ends
for everybody i think
the awareness is there for that but i
think a little bit the numbers and the
actions um yeah divide from that a
little bit
because we've seen now the past weekend
the g7
have donated vaccines but it's it's not
enough they've
announced 870 million doses the who has
responded and
said thank you that is a good effort but
actually we need 11 billion doses
so we see there is a divide in the
action and also with the voluntary
licenses
yes there are deals being made but not
enough
for the global demand that we are seeing
you mentioned the tech transfer that has
to happen the licensing problem
there's also the export ban problem
india being such a big
producer what needs to change there
i think all these um yeah all these
hindrance all these barriers
for more global production and global
distribution needs to be worked on and
they need to be lifted because
there's no such thing as only the patent
barrier needs to be lifted only the
export ban needs to be lifted
there needs to be a combined effort of
all these things there needs to be a
waving of patents
export bans and a sharing of technology
and know-how only then
will we have a fast scale up and more
vaccines for people worldwide faster
elizabeth masouda from doctors without
borders thank you very much for being on
the show today
thank you time for your questions on the
coronavirus over to our science
correspondent
derek williams
[Music]
a friend refuses to get a vaccine
because he believes fetal tissue was
used in their development
is this true this topic is a really
tricky one to talk about and there's
plenty of room for ethical debate
but but i want to just focus as much as
possible
on the science first of all let's get
one
associated social media rumor out of the
way
covid19 vaccines do not contain
fetal cells or fetal dna those
are not components or active ingredients
in any vaccine however
what are known as fetal cell lines
have been used or are being used in
different ways
for the development and and sometimes
the production
of various vaccines a fetal cell line
is a line of cells that was established
in the past
from an electively aborted fetus
that can be propagated in the lab
practically
indefinitely the cell lines used for
covet 19 vaccine production and
development
were first isolated many decades ago
now that these cell lines have been used
as tools
in the development of covid19 vaccine
should not
in and of itself come as much of a
surprise to anybody
fetal cell lines have been used for well
over over half a century to develop
and produce a wide range of vaccines
for other diseases from from hepatitis
to chickenpox and those vaccines
have prevented a huge amount of
suffering
and death critics of methods that employ
fetal cell lines say that more should be
done
to promote alternative systems
proponents on the other hand
argue that other systems are less
effective
leaders from the world's major religions
are of course
divided on the complex question of
whether or not
vaccines made with the help of fetal
cell lines
are morally and ethically
acceptable but but many of those leaders
while ambivalent about such vaccines
have also not prescribed them
and japanese companies are helping out
with the country's sluggish vaccination
drive ahead of the olympics
the head of software firm softbank has
been showing the vaccinations minister
around his company's own vaccination
center in tokyo
softbank says it'll set up 15 others
like it and not just for
employees so far only 13 of japanese
population has received a shot
tokyo is under a state of emergency just
weeks before the games are set to begin
thanks for watching stay safe
[Music]